okay cool right then so welcome
everybody to this session thank you for
choosing to join us today i hope this is
going to be fun
and useful to you so my name is
steve and i work at microsoft i'm on the
asp.net team
and the main thing that i focus on at
the moment is this thing
that we're talking about today which is
blazer
and i know many of you will know about
this already
but i think also a fair number of people
may not so what i'm going to do in this
talk is i will try to
balance a little bit there some intro
content with some deeper investigations
into certain features of blazer which i
hope you will all find useful
so let's get a look at what we're going
to talk about so like i said we're going
to start with a little bit of
introductory content to set the scene
for anyone who's not quite sure
what this stuff is about and why they
should care but that will only take a
few minutes
uh we will go through some getting
started content and then
we will look for the majority of the
time into
what stuff is in blazer webassembly
which we have just
shipped so what is blazer and what is
the point of
any of this well let's imagine that your
job as a web developer
is to build a rich web application
that your customers can use and maybe
they need to use it
inside a regular desktop web browser
maybe they need to use it
as something more like an installable
app on their mobile devices
and within this application let's
imagine that you need to do some really
sophisticated stuff
you want a very rich ui with many many
different kinds of things going on there
you're going to have
grids you're going to have sidebars
dialogues wizards drop-downs all
all the things that you could ever
reasonably have inside
a ui but you've also got lots of other
concerns to think about as well
you've got things like uh authentication
authorization other security things
you're gonna have to deal with things
like localization you're gonna have to
deal
with uh just many many different
cross-cutting concerns
that affects modern application
development
so how are you going to build something
like this what kind of technology
would you use well if we go back in time
a few years
then your only option to build something
that runs in a browser
would have been one of these kinds of
things a javascript
framework and you would have had to
write your code in javascript or
something that compiles to javascript
like typescript and that's fine that's
all very well people
did that for many years and have been
successful with doing that but
it's not it's not great for our industry
if that's the only option that people
have got because within software there
are many other kinds of languages
frameworks programming paradigms and
it's
a bit of a shame if they're all shut out
from web development but
the good side of this the good news is
that
thanks to modern web standards we're not
actually limited to just using one
kind of language anymore and this is
where blazer comes in
so blazer is a ui technology
for the web that lets you build these
kinds of rich web applications
using net code and this is thanks to the
ability to do things like
real-time web sockets connections and
the ability to run
code on webassembly inside browsers and
what are the advantages of doing that
why would anyone care about this well
probably the
the main advantage that people do care
about is the ability to use the c-sharp
language and net so c-sharp has been
well established for many years
as being a highly productive and
effective language to build
large-scale robust applications which is
the sort of thing that many of you
are doing today and alongside that comes
with some really
excellent tooling and ide support you
know arguably
best in industry type tooling there with
that we have in the form of visual
studio
and visual studio for mac and vs code
and then separately from that there's
the rest of the dotnet ecosystem which
is a very consistent and stable world so
unlike some other software
ecosystems.net is not changing every few
months it's not constantly
getting you to build stuff according to
different best practices that are always
changing
dotnet tends to be stable over long
periods of time and that's
uh kind of deliberately by design so
hopefully the
investments that you make into building
a rich web app with
net will pay off for many years to come
okay so when you build a blazer
application
there are two main ways that you can
deploy that and host that
on the internet the first mechanism is
something called blazer server
and we have had that for a little while
so that shipped
initially with net core 3 back in
november last year
and in this model your net code your
blazer components run
on the server somewhere so probably in a
cloud environment somewhere
and whenever you want to display some ui
in someone's browser or
wherever you want to react to something
that the user does
all that information is being sent over
a real-time websocket connection via
signalr
so that things can update on the fly so
that's been around for a little while
and many people are using that
but the newer version of blazer which
just shipped about three weeks ago
at build is blazer webassembly and
that's something that people have been
waiting for for a long time and in some
ways that's a simpler model because in
this model
your.net code and your components just
run directly inside the browser
on a.net runtime that we have compiled
to webassembly so that it can run in
standard
uh web browsers desktop and mobile
without the use of any plugins just
purely
on modern web standards okay so that's a
super high level
overview of what kind of problem this is
supposed to solve now the
cool and exciting news is like i just
mentioned that blazer web assembly is
now
fully released and that is quite a
big exciting and relieving thing from my
point of view because i've been working
on building this uh with a team for more
than two years now i think we've done
more than 17
pre-releases and got a lot of feedback
from the community and built up a big
group of enthusiastic users so it's a
big
uh excitement to finally have that to be
fully released and supported
for production use if you want to
do that then the way to get started is
pretty straightforward
because i think a lot of people have
seen this already i'm not actually going
to give you any demos of creating new
projects from scratch
if you want to see that you can go and
find many other videos online or read
the documentation
probably the best way to get started is
to go to blazer.net
and that will give you some setup
instructions
for whichever kind of coding environment
and ide you wish to use so if you want
to use visual studio on windows
or for mac or whether you prefer to use
visual studio code
all of those are going to work really
well for you and you can find
information about that on blazer.net
but in this talk i don't want to focus
too much on getting started because i'm
aware that many people will already know
about that
so let's think instead about some of the
cool
and useful features that i've shipped
just a few weeks ago
in blazer webassembly and to do that
we're going to need
to have an application that we can build
and i've got a starting point
application for us to work from
it's a fairly sophisticated application
that will demonstrate a lot of different
features and i will go through showing
you
some of the code behind each of those
things and along the way hopefully we
can add a new
a few new features to the application so
you get a sense of what coding with this
is like so here's a an application
starting point for us it's something
called car checker
which is a demo app that we've been
using uh quite a bit over the last month
or so
and i'm going to start it up in my
browser now and then i'll quickly talk
you through
what kind of scenario this is meant to
be for
so if i start that up i'm going to use
ctrl f5 to start that in the browser
without the debugger because that makes
it come up nice and fast
and when it does come up you'll see that
the only thing that a user can do when
they get started
is login so who would log in
who is this application for anyway well
this application
is designed for a car rentals company so
you know what it's like if you go
and rent a car you go you take it you
drive it around for a week or so
and then you bring it back to the car
rentals company and you have to check it
back in with them
and some staff member comes out and they
look at the vehicle and they check
things like
have you fueled it up correctly have you
added too much mileage
have you caused any damage anywhere on
the car and they need to record
information that they find
when they're looking at the vehicle that
they're checking back in so that's what
this
application is for so the person logging
in would be a staff member
at the car rentals company so let's
pretend that we're a staff member now
and i'm going to
log in and i've already registered a
user account for myself
so i'm going to put the username and
password in there
and then when i get back to the
application you'll see that i'm now
logged in
and i've got a few more things i can do
for example i can go and manage my
account
or i can go and synchronize stuff with
the server via this update button
and we'll talk more about what that
means in a minute but let's pretend
that a customer has just brought a
vehicle back to us and we need to check
it now
well we can start typing its license
number in and we get this nice
autocomplete kind of thing going on
there so let's say it's this one here
and i'll click on that and we'll now get
into
the vehicle details editor
okay so what the staff member would do
probably
is they would go and look at the mileage
on the car that's being returned and
they would want to update that
inside the ui so maybe they come along
and they type in some absolutely crazy
implausible value
and you can see we've got some forms and
validation stuff kicking in there so
let's just
change that to something else maybe this
customer returned it just half full
so we'd want to track that and you can
see over here on the right that this
save button has now shown up
and that's because blazer has a built-in
forms and validation system
that keeps track of the state of the
form and it knows that there are some
unchanged unsaved changes and then
the the staff member could also walk
around the vehicle
in real life and compare it with this 3d
view which shows us where damage has
already
been recorded on the vehicle and they
can maybe add some information about any
new damage that they find
so let's imagine that there's some
problem with
this headlight here they could choose
that and then they could go into add
note
maybe they try to save it without typing
any description in and they get
validation
and they can then type in some actual
description like
absolutely destroyed
okay and then they could save their
changes on there and then they could hit
save again
and that will save the changes back to
the server and if they don't
remember to press the save changes
button then we'll know that we should
prompt them to save their changes
or not in this case i'm not going to all
right so
quite a lot of things going on inside
the application there
and one other thing i want to show you
before we get into the code
is how this might look on a mobile
device because this application is
really designed to be used from mobile
because you know when some staff member
is walking around vehicles in a
parking lot they probably don't want to
be carrying a laptop with them
so let's see how this might look on an
actual mobile
so i've got my phone here and i'm going
to
share the screen of it with you so there
it is and
then you'll see that i've got this chart
car checker application installed onto
my home screen we'll talk about how that
works in a minute and when i go into
there
then the same application will now show
up and this is still blazer running
on webassembly but we've got slightly
different layout now that makes use of
the mobile screen
you'll see it doesn't have any browser
address bars and it fills up the whole
area of the screen including the
curved areas and i can still go and find
a vehicle
i've got a slightly different layout now
but i can still use the the
3d view i can still go and add some
information about damage
and if i was to try and add a photo
you'll see the browser's native ui for
taking photos or
using the photo picker appears and
excuse the french on that we'll talk
about localization a little bit
later on okay so that's a quick overview
of what this application
looks like let's now start digging in to
some aspects of how
it's implemented okay
so we are going to go through six
different
areas of the code and in each case i'll
show you a little bit
about how it's been set up and then
hopefully we can also
add some extra features to really
understand how this works a little bit
more and the first area that we're going
to look at is
authorization okay so security in
general is obviously a very important
topic in web applications
and there's quite a lot of functionality
that's baked into
blazer as a client-side technology as
well as asp.net core as a server-side
one
and they all tie together so let's have
a look at a little bit
of that now i already showed you that i
could log in
and in fact i can get back to the
account management thing from here and
if i do click that
if you're an asp.net developer you might
recognize this kind of ui
already this is asp.net core's
built-in identity system which is a
built-in way
of managing user accounts and letting
users set up all the
stuff to do with their account and
two-factor authentication and stuff like
that
and the point i'm showing you this is
just to say that that is fully
integrated with blazer webassembly so
when you create your project
you get various options about how you
want to do auth
and one of those options is simply to
use the asp.net core
server side identity system but that's
not the only option that you've got
we actually support the use of any open
id connect
compatible provider so if you want to do
login using
azure active directory or google logins
or any other
oidc compliant provider then you can
absolutely do that and that's going to
work great
but in this case i'm using the backend
asp.net core application
as my login system okay so that's how
users can log in
but there's more that you need to do
than just let people log in
for example you may want to lock down
access
to certain server side data endpoints
that's kind of the whole point of
security in the first place really we
don't we don't care so much about what
people see in the ui
as we do about what data they can access
and modify
on the back end so how does that
integrate with blazer webassembly well
let's have a go at locking down our
application
a little bit in fact let's start by
looking at a bit of the code that we've
got in here
so inside my solution you can see i've
got these three projects i've got this
client project here
which is the actual blazer webassembly
application and we'll be going through
quite a bit of the code
in there soon we've also got this server
side project
which is an asp.net core server which is
dealing with the actual data storage in
the login system
now blazer webassembly doesn't require
you to use asp.net core on the server
it can be used with any server side
technology or even non i'll show you
that later
but if you are using asp.net core on the
server then you get some pretty good
integrations now the first one of these
that we're going to talk about is
auth so let's imagine that i want to
lock down my server side data a little
bit
i'm going to go to this vehicle
controller here that's a server-side mvc
controller
that exposes things about the list of
vehicles that have been changed or lets
you actually
put a modification to a vehicle record
in the database
and at the moment it has no access
control at all it's just publicly
readable and writable by the whole world
and that's not really what we want
so i'm going to add this authorize
attribute here
and if you are an asp.net developer
already you will recognize that
that's the standard way of limiting
access to
a controller and because i haven't
provided any extra detail that's just
going to lock it down to
users who are logged in i could add a i
could implement more detailed policies
than that if i want but this is good
enough for now
you can access this if and only if you
are logged in
so let's see how the client application
behaves now that data is protected
if i reload over here then initially it
might appear to be more or less the same
but if you look at the bottom you'll see
it now says could not sync
okay what's actually going on there
let's have a look at the network trace
here
so when i click this retry button a
couple of times you'll see that the
server is responding with the status 401
not authorized
and that's because the servant now only
accepts requests from people who are
logged in
and so you might be thinking well i am
logged in look we can see the username
right there
clearly you are logged in why does it
act as if you're not logged in
well the answer to that is because i've
deliberately
disconnected an important part of how
these two things integrate just so that
i can show it to you
so by default when you create your
project with this kind of
auth it automatically knows that
whenever you make
http requests to the back end it should
include the auth tokens that the server
has issued
so that the server knows you're logged
in but in this case i've commented that
out just so that i could show it to you
so let's see where that actually is if i
go into my program cs
this is inside my client-side
application that runs on webassembly
and this is where all the global
configuration of my application works
and i don't expect you to recognize or
understand all the code that's in here
but i just want you to notice that this
line of code here is commented out
uh i'm going to uncomment it just so
that it goes back to its default
behavior that the project template gives
us and what that does is it says
whenever we're making requests to the
base address
that is the url that the application is
hosted on we're going to
include the authorization tokens that's
what this particular message handler
does and that's there by default
normally so now if i have that
back to its usual behavior and i hit
reload then instead of getting these
error messages
hopefully it's now going to go back to
working normally
and if i click this button a couple of
times you'll see that the server is
responding with
200 okay and if we look in there in
slightly
more detail we can see in the uh
request headers that we're sending to
the server
from the client here that we've included
this authorization token which is what
the server issued
when we first logged in so that's why
the server knows who we are
and of course you can do way more stuff
with auth than just that but that
hopefully gives you a bit of a sense
of how things can be wired together
between server and client
and it illustrates how things are set up
by default
okay so that's enough about that let's
move on to an another area that i think
will be of interest
and this is to do with code sharing and
i'm going to talk about this from a
couple of different
angles because this is one of the real
strengths of blazer webassembly
and the first way that i'm going to talk
about it is to do this sharing code
across different parts of your own
application
code your own solution so if we go back
to
yes here and we look you'll see that
like i mentioned before
we've got these two different with three
projects we've got the client project
here
we've got the server project and finally
we've got this shared project
now shared is nothing special there's no
magic going on here that's just
a plain old net standard class library
but one of the great things about
having.net
as a full stack language used on both
the client and the server is that you
can trivially share code between your
server and client
just by having a common project that
both of them reference and that's
something that people very commonly do
when they're defining things like domain
model classes
that want to be used in both places so
in this example here i've got for
example the
vehicle class that defines all the
different properties and metadata that
we have about vehicles we've also got
this
inspection note class that's what i've
been creating whenever i add
information about damage to one of the
cars okay
now this shared uh set of classes
is used for quite a lot of things we're
using reusing it in a few different ways
so the first way is that this structure
of properties and metadata
actually defines the schema of the
server-side database the sql database
on the server has its shape
automatically set up to match this
these classes and all of these
properties and metadata
so that's the first way the second way
it's used is that this metadata is
uh defines the server-side validation
rules that are enforced
every time we make http requests to the
server thirdly
they define the client-side validation
rules that are used within the ui when
you're editing a form
and fourthly they define the shape of
the traffic that's exchanged between the
client and the server so the actual
network wire format
and all four of those things are always
guaranteed to be consistent because they
are
all coming from a single source of truth
there
so that's a really handy way of sharing
information
and just to illustrate that let's add an
extra validation rule
so far adding photos has been optional
let's say that it's now required
so i'm going to say that photo url is
now mandatory
and there's going to be an error message
if you don't give it and i'll say all
damage must be photographed
like that okay so let's rebuild that and
that is now going to change the behavior
of both the client side and the server
side code
let's see what that does so if i go back
now and i hit reload so that the changes
are applied
then i'll go back into that car that we
saw earlier
and let's say that i want to uh have a
look at this
part of the car the body front left okay
i open this now and you'll see
that actually i want to edit the
existing note rather than add another
one
okay so if i try to hit the save button
now you'll see that i can't save it
anymore
because all damage must be photographed
okay
so how can we add a photo of the damage
here
well i could click on this take new
button but nothing happens when i do
that because
i haven't actually implemented the
ability to pick photos yet
and that takes us on to the next way of
sharing code which is sharing code
across the entire ecosystem using nuget
packages
so blazer webassembly does not have a
built-in way
of picking photos or files but there are
nuget packages that can do that for us
and i'm going to do that inside my
client project right now so i'm going to
right click on there and go manage new
get packages
and i'm going to search for a package to
do that and i happen to know it already
exists
that i want this one blazer input file
and that is a
general purpose way of picking files uh
which could be photos or something else
and then you can do whatever you want
with the data that's inside those files
okay so now how am i going to use that
well we haven't actually looked at any
of the blazer component
code yet so if you have never seen this
before
it's probably worth explaining a couple
of details about that
within this class within this project
here i've got all these different razer
files each one of the razer files is a
ui component
it combines both markup and logic and
you can build a structure of these
components
to define your application ui for
example
we've got this vehicle note editor
okay and if we go in here this is quite
a sophisticated component so
it's if it's the first one you've ever
seen then i apologize for kind of
throwing you in at the deep end here but
within here you can see that there's a
lot of stuff going on we can use the
dependency injection system
we can render other components
hierarchically we can use
html markup to render stuff we can have
uh c-sharp expressions in the middle of
our markup that all get rendered
efficiently
and down here you can see we can have
c-sharp source code
to implement the actual behavior of the
component and there are many different
ways you can do that but in this case
what i want to do
is add a photo picker here we've got a
bit of an html form
where it's got this caption about photo
and it's displaying validation messages
and such
now i've just added that package called
blazer input file
that means i've got access to this input
file component that's inside there
initially it's qualified by a namespace
i don't really want that so let's
take that away and i'm going to add a
using statement here
so that i've got the blazer input file
namespace available
and now i can just use input file
directly without having to qualify it
now to save us a bit of time i've
already prepared the code that we want
here
so i want to have an input file and i'm
also going to say that i only want to
accept images
so that will affect how the behavior in
the browser is and it makes mobile
devices use the photo picker and so on
and then i'm saying when you pick
something i want to call this c-sharp
method
handle photo selected which doesn't
exist yet hence the red squigglies so
i'll scroll down to all of my event
handlers
and i'm going to put in the logic i want
and the logic i want is this
the user is going to pick one or more
files in fact they can only pick one
files because i didn't make it a
multi-select
so we'll take the first source file from
the list and we'll represent it as a
jpeg image with this certain
maximum resolution and we'll read all
the bytes from there
we're going to use that as the photo on
this particular
domain model class and that will
hopefully satisfy the validation rules
and it will also get stored in the
database so
when i rebuild that and i go back and
reload
hopefully i'll be able to actually pick
a photo this time
and then i will be allowed to save my
changes so here i'm going to click on
this and now you see
a file picker appears and the actual
behavior and appearance of that depends
on what kind of browser or operating
system you're in
on a mobile it would use the photo
picker and then i'm going to hit save on
that
and you'll see the validation rules are
now satisfied but i have only satisfied
validation rules for this one thing
these other two notes don't have photos
yet so when i try to save that
you'll see i get this error message here
the server is rejecting this
change because it hasn't satisfied all
of the rules
on the server so that just goes to show
that validation isn't enforced on both
sides of the wire
so to get past that problem i'm just
going to delete these other two things
so i don't have to have photos on them
and then i'll hit save and now this time
my change will successfully
go through okay so there's quite a bit
of code sharing stuff
next topic to talk about javascript
interrupt so why would you want to do
that well
kind of the point of blazer is to let
you write as much of your application ui
logic as possible in.net code
so why would you want to use javascript
well there are lots of reasons actually
one of them is that the javascript
ecosystem is massive and there's loads
of really useful
third-party components that you might
want to use in your application
and blazer applications should be able
to use those perfectly easily
and another reason is of course that the
browser apis themselves that are built
into the browser
are exposed in the form of javascript
and you're going to need to be able to
call those
from.net so blazer is a system for
calling javascript
from.net and for calling.net from
javascript and i can show you examples
of that now
so the first example that i'll show you
is something you've already been seeing
which is this 3d view here
now this 3d view is not actually
implemented italian.net code
behind the scenes there it uses the 3js
library which is a very popular
third-party javascript library for 3d
rendering
so how is that being used within our
application well
let's have a look if i go into this
index component here
you'll see not index vehicle editor you
will see
that we've got this scene view component
and that component is not defined in my
project that's actually coming from a
nuget package
and that wraps up everything that i need
to integrate with 3js
in a reusable way that makes it feel
just like normal.net programming
so i can pass stuff to it like what
skybox to use what object
to render i can tell it what stuff to
highlight
which in this case is the damaged parts
of the car and i can even have a
callback
so that my c-sharp event handlers fire
when the user clicks on a particular
part within that 3d view
so that's how you can pull in
third-party
dependencies that wrap up all the
javascript interrupt for you so you
don't have to see any javascript
yourself so that's the easiest way of
doing javascript interrupt
but there'll also be some times where
you need to write your own javascript
code
and interact with it directly from.net
and so
let me show you an example of that right
now an example of that
in this application is to do with how
the data is stored
because one of the business requirements
for this application is that it needs to
work offline
and i hope the reason for that should
seem fairly natural
since the person who's inspecting these
cars will probably have to walk out into
a big
car park or parking lot to inspect the
vehicles they can't really guarantee
that they're going to have wi-fi access
all the time so the application needs to
be able to start up when you're offline
and you need to be able to make edits
and save them even while you're offline
and then eventually synchronize those
changes back to the server
so to port support that we've got a
client-side database and i can show you
that in the browser dev tools here
it's something that's built into
browsers called index db
okay and if we look in here you can see
here's information about my local
database it's called vehicles
it's got three tables in it one in which
we track the local edits that we haven't
sent to the server yet another one
that's got some general metadata
and then finally we've got this table in
which we synchronize all the stuff that
we know about the database from the
server
and this synchronizes incrementally so
it's perfectly okay even if it's a giant
database
and we're getting the list of all the
cards that are known at this
particular rental location which might
be quite a large number
but we need all of them so that the user
can search through that database
even while they're offline okay how does
this
work then so how do we get access to
indexeddb from netcode
well there's a couple of steps to that
and one of them is to write some
javascript and i've got this javascript
file here called local vehicle store
and if you've not seen this sort of
thing before it might seem a bit scary
at first but it's not too bad
because we've only got 36 lines of code
in there and
within that 36 lines we're defining the
database schema
up here and that includes these three
tables that i showed you as well as
their
primary keys and indexes that sort of
thing it's pretty simple
api and then we've also got these
general purpose
functions for accessing that data so we
can get stuff from a particular
store or table uh we can get all of the
things we can put stuff in there we can
delete stuff
and we've even got this application
specific query here
which we're using for autocomplete so
when you type stuff in
uh it's going to search for the first n
items in a given
table and then to access this from
netcode
we've got a class here called local
vehicle store
and i'm making that available through
dependency injection to any part of the
application that needs it
and that uses this ijs runtime interface
to make calls into javascript for
example if we want to get a list of the
outstanding unsynchronized edits we
simply say
get me everything from the local edits
table and deserialize that as a set of
vehicle objects and when we want to
synchronize we can say okay
get all the local edits for each one of
them i want to do a put request to send
that to the server
and then assuming that the server says
this was successful
then delete the local copy of it and
when we're done with all that we'll
finally fetch any unsynchronized changes
from the server so hopefully you'll see
that that's a fairly
neat self-contained way of interacting
with javascript stuff
from.net code whether it's your own
javascript or third-party javascript
okay so next topic debugging obviously
there will be times where you need to be
able to debug
your.net code but is it actually
possible
to debug.netcode that's running on
webassembly inside a browser
well my application up now with the
debugger so i pressed the f5 key
and that tells my ide to start up a new
instance of the browser
which is listening for debugger
connections and then visual studio will
connect to that and start my application
up in it and now hopefully i can start
doing
some debugging okay so let's see what do
we want to debug
well let's go back to this car we've
been working on here
and you'll remember that i added a photo
a little bit earlier
and you might have noticed this detect
damage button shows up so what's that
well
this is kind of a bit independent of
blazer really but it's kind of cool so
we put it in anyway
when you press this detect damage button
it sends the
photo data to the server which then runs
a machine learning model an ml.net model
over it
to detect any damage to the vehicle that
shows up in that photo
so we know whether the customer has to
be charged or not so that's a bit
separate from blazer but it gives us
an example of something that we might
want to debug so let's see
we'll go into our client-side code that
runs on webassembly
we've got this component called damage
detection and this is where that stuff
happens when you click the button
we've got this c-sharp method called
perform damage detection
and i'm going to put a breakpoint in
there before we send the data to the
server
and another break point when we get the
response back from the server
but i also want to debug my server side
code too
so in the server code i'll find the
detect damage controller which receives
the data
and i'll put a break point in there as
well
so now in the browser when i click on
this detect damage button
we'll find that it hits a breakpoint
inside our code that's running on
webassembly
and we can do the usual debugging type
gestures so i can hover over here and
see that
this flag is currently false but if i
step then the flag now becomes true
i could also step through this process
of getting the data and sending it to
the server but i'm just going to press
f5
and now we will hit the server-side
breakpoint and we can continue debugging
and stepping through the server-side
code
and see how the machine learning model
does its thing but i'm going to press f5
and then after the model runs it's going
to hopefully hit the breakpoint back
in the client-side code as well and if
we want to
we can now even hover over this damage
detection result
and we can see that the server is saying
that this car is damaged and we've got
this
certain confidence level and we can
press f5 one more time
and now we get back into the browser ui
where you can see that the ui has been
updated and we get the information that
we expected
so the point of me showing you this
thing is just to say that yes
you can use the normal debugger gestures
to debug your
client-side code but more than that you
can do full stack debugging where you've
got code running across server and
client
and you can step through that process of
calls that go between server and client
and debug them both at the same time now
i only showed you that in visual studio
but the same thing is true
in vs code as well it's a slightly
different process for launching the
debugger there but it also does work
and you can go and see the docs if you
want to know more about that
so let's close that instance of the
browser down and i'm going to get back
into the one that doesn't have a
debugger
attached okay right then so that's uh
enough about debugging
what else should we talk about well how
about internationalization
if you are building an application for a
global audience
it's probably not good enough to just
build it in one language and have one
fixed set
of culture settings you probably need to
account for the needs of different users
around the world
so let's imagine that we are a large
global car rental company
and some of our users speak a different
language let's try changing the browser
language settings
if i go over here into the language
settings you can see that i've got
english uk as my default preferred
language but i'm going to change it so
that spanish
is my preferred language and now back in
the browser when i reload
hopefully you will see that the whole ui
now shows up
in spanish all the strings which are
built into the application are in
spanish
but of course not any strings that are
entered by the user because we're not
you know magically translating stuff
it's only stuff that we've provided
translations for
it's perhaps a little more obvious still
if we go back to the homepage
where we've now got bienv bienvenido
sorry about my pronunciation there and
all of the ui is
in spanish including things like
validation messages
okay so how does that work well again if
you're an asp.net developer you'll
find this quite familiar let's see how
this thing
is set up if i go into my di
configuration again
you'll see one of the services that is
registered in this application
is called is the localization service
and
in this case i've configured it to say i
want to get my resources
out of this directory called resources
and that's inside my application here
so you can see i've got these resex
files inside that directory
and that provides translations and i can
create as many of those as i want for
different cultures
and blazer webassembly is smart enough
to only download the ones
that are applicable to the current user
so you don't have to worry about adding
loads of them
okay now to understand that a little bit
more
let's add a bit of extra localization
because there's one part of my
application i haven't localized yet
if i open this you can see that these
two strings manage account and log out
are still in english so why are they
still in english
if we go to where that is defined
which is the login status component here
you will see
that we have got these two strings
that are hard-coded in english and i
want them to be
translated how can we translate strings
well
i'll show you in a different component
that is already translated
so the index component and you can see
that it injects
this string localization string
localizer service
which is the same thing that is
available in asp.net core
on the server and you can use that to
access the contents of your resex
translations so for example to translate
into license number all we do is we
simply read that string out
of the localizer and that will fetch the
best translation that's available for
this user
and if there is no translation available
it will just return the string
exactly as it is okay so let's have a go
at using that
inside login status you can see i've
already injected it here at the top
there
so now instead of just hard coding that
string i'm going to read it
out of the localizer okay
so i've done that now let's see if that
is sufficient
to get the translations to appear in the
ui
okay so we just wait for that to rebuild
and then i'll go back and i'll hit
reload
and we'll see if our text now shows up
in spanish
the answer is no it does not it's still
english why is that well the reason for
that is because
localize is not magic and it doesn't
actually know how to translate stuff
until you actually provide translations
for it
one of the nice things about it is that
if it doesn't have translations it's not
an
error it just uses the string as it is
so for you as a developer you're not
required to speak every language in the
world
uh you don't have to speak anything
other than your own language you can
just use localize around all the strings
and from your point of view nothing will
change but it means that later on
someone can come and provide
translations for whatever set of
languages they want
and they will just show up at the right
time so let's add some translations for
these two
i'm going to go to my spanish res x file
here where you can see i've got all
these translations already
these were helpfully provided by javier
on the team who
not only speaks spanish but also uh
implemented a lot of blazer so thanks
for that have you
and i am going to go and put these two
entries in there manage account and log
out
and then i'll use the translations that
i've been given so this is the spanish
for log out i'm going to put in there
and then similarly for
administrate account or manage account
that
will be there okay so i'll rebuild one
more time
and this time we actually do have the
translations
so hopefully when i reload instead of
seeing that text
in english we're going to see it in the
user's preferred language
at last and there we go we do so it's
now fully in spanish
and of course if i want to and i do i
can switch myself back
into english and when i reload then
everything
is going to go back into english again
okay
so it's not limited to just translating
strings blazer webassembly also
has globalization support in by default
so when it comes to things like entering
numbers
formatting dates and such like uh they
will automatically respect the user's
thread culture and we also have support
for time zones as well so when you print
out
dates and times in local time zone uh
they will show up correctly for the
given
user okay so that's quite a lot of stuff
there let's move on now to our final
topic
and this is the area where everything
we've seen so far
kind of comes together into one
beautiful harmony
that is progressive web apps so what's a
pwa well
if you didn't know a progressive web app
is a way of building and
using a web application that behaves a
little bit more
like a native desktop application so
that means things like
it can be installed into your operating
system and it'll show up on your start
menu or your
home screen or dock whatever your os has
it also means that you could
use it offline without needing any kind
of network connectivity
and other things like the ability to
send and receive
push notifications from a back-end
server even when the user is not
actually using your application
so quite a lot of stuff that pwas can do
and blazer webassembly
is a true client-side technology so it
can take use take advantage of all of
that stuff
and we've got support for this built
into the project template when you
create your project
you can simply check a box to say if you
want it to be a pwa
and that's what i've done when i set up
this car checker
application and one of the things it
does is it creates this file called
manifest.json
and that tells the browser that you want
this application to be installable and
how it should look when it is installed
so
you specify a name you can specify an
icon and various things to do with theme
colors
and by virtue of having that file if we
look in the browser closely
you'll notice that we've got this little
plus button up here
that is offering to let the user install
this
into their device so if i click on this
install button right now
you'll see that rather than being inside
the browser it now shows up in its own
separate window now behind the scenes
this is a browser but as far as a
regular
civilian end user is concerned it's it
doesn't look like a browser it doesn't
have an address bar and
it can have whatever styles in it you
want so it behaves and looks just like a
native application
including things like being launchable
from the start menu and you can put it
on your
home screen or doc or whatever so if i
start searching now for car checker
you'll see that's there
on my start menu since i'm in windows
and i can start that up again
and this is still blazer running on
webassembly and it's going to have all
the same functionality
that we saw before okay now what about
running offline does this thing work
offline and how could we
test that well like i said behind the
scenes this is still a browser even
though it
doesn't look like one and we can still
get into the browser dev tools
if i go to inspect here you'll see the
browser dev tools
show up okay and using these i can
simulate being
offline if i want to so there we go i'm
telling the browser i want to pretend
that we're offline
and i want to simulate what it's like to
start the application when you're
offline
so i'm going to right click and go to
refresh and this will be just like what
happens if you've got no network
connectivity
and you try to start the application
does it work the answer is
no it does not we just get an error
message saying you're not connected
so what on earth is going on there
you're probably thinking
uh you've just been telling me that pwas
can work offline
and that this is a pwa so why doesn't it
work offline
that's a very good and fair question the
answer is that
within the project template by default
we've set it up
so that offline support is only enabled
when you've published your application
not in development and there's a good
reason for that the reason
is that when you've got an offline first
pwa whenever you change the application
those updates aren't applied
instantly they're rolled out
asynchronously in the background
and that could be very annoying to you
during development because when you make
a change you want to see your change
show up
as quickly as possible you don't want to
wait for some kind of async process
to take place in the background so
that's why we only do offline support
in uh production so if i want to show
this to you i'm going to have to
actually publish
my application and i can do that quite
easily i could do it from my ide in
visual studio
but i kind of like doing publishing from
the command line
because i find the experience a little
bit faster to just type in one command
like that
so that's going to publish my
application to a folder
on my local hard drive and it takes a
few moments because during the publish
process
this is when we run tree shaking or
linking as we call it
to strip out all the unused code it's
also when we do a
very aggressive form of broadly
pre-compression to try and shrink your
application down
even further so that'll take a few
moments to go through
and when it does go through i'll be able
to just run it
locally so hopefully that'll be finished
in a few seconds and i can stop
trying to fill in the time come on
there we go right it's done so now i'm
going to switch into the directory
where it's been published to and i'm
going to start up the
uh application in its published form so
that's now listening on this port
8080 and i'm going to go into my browser
and
start that up okay so here that comes
and let's see if that's working well
i've slightly confused it by changing
the port so i'm going to log out and log
myself
back in again so let's go back to log in
and i'll use the same account as before
okay so now hopefully i'm fully logged
in
to the production published version of
my application
and i could install it again as a pwa if
i wanted to uh either on desktop
like i showed you before but it's just
the same to use in a browser so just
like before
i'm going to go to the dev tools and i'm
going to say i want to simulate being
offline okay so i'm offline now and then
just like before i'm going to reload the
page
and we'll see do we get an error this
time the answer is
no we do not get an error it actually
comes up and it works
well we've actually got quite a few
errors in the network trace
because we're trying to talk to the
server but we can't anymore because
there is no
network access and hence we cannot
synchronize our changes
but the application is still going to
work you know i can still search through
the database
i can still go in and start making edits
like i'm going to change the fuel level
to half here
and then i'll hit save and you can see
we still can't synchronize but we know
that there's an onsen
edit and that's safely stored in the
local indexeddb
even restart the application and
my edit is still there and available so
let's imagine now that as a staff member
we've checked in a few cars without
network access
and then we walk back over to where the
office is and we resume
the wi-fi connection so we get wi-fi
signal back
and now we hit the retry button again
what happens is that our changes now
go through happily so that's all very
nice okay so
that is making an offline capable pwa
with blazer web assembly all right so
that's all the main features i want to
show you
one last thing i'm going to show you
really quickly is not really a feature
so much as it is just a kind of an
inherent behavior
of client-side web applications which is
that we can do
pure static file hosting i already said
that you don't have to have
net core on the server if you don't want
to you can host a blazer webassembly app
from any server technology whether
that's
node or ruby or python anything else
that you like it's fine
you can even host it from a web server
that doesn't even support dynamic code
you can host on a pure static file host
like azure static sites or github pages
anything like that that you want and to
really prove that to you i'm just going
to show you
a blazer webassembly application which
is running on github pages
so if i go to this git repo here which
is public you can go visit
yourself right now if you want to this
is the default blazer project template
deployed to github pages so there's no
server side code going on here
if i follow this link here this is the
the standard blazer project template
which you've probably seen before if
you've ever seen any blazer
stuff or tried it yourself and it's all
fully functional it's running out.net
code
on webassembly inside the browser it
supports navigation and it supports deep
linking everything that you'd expect
and it even serves it efficiently with
broadly pre-compression
the way this all works is mainly it just
works
naturally because as far as the server
is concerned we're just serving static
content
and the browser doesn't care what it
where it comes from the only bits that
i've customized for github
is that i've added a few things in order
to make it served more efficiently
with broccoli compression and if you
want to come and see how that works
then just come and look at this git repo
and see exactly what i've done
but the real point that i'm making is
that when you choose to build a blazer
webassembly application you've got a
huge amount of flexibility about how
it's deployed
and if you want to you can have globally
distributed
static file hosting completely free
using something like github pages and
blazer webassembly can be served
like that so that's nearly all
that we're going to have time for we
might even get time to answer a few
questions so if you have questions i
would encourage you to come and post
them in the slack
channel here and i'm going to come back
in a minute or two and i'll see what
questions
i can answer but just while you're
typing out your questions
let me address one thing that i think
will come up which is what's next
for blazer okay so blazer webassembly
has shipped blazer server has been
shipped for a while so
what on earth does the blazer team spend
its time doing these days well
the answer is we are already hard at
work building
blazer internet five so the next preview
release of dot net five or
or whenever it does come out the preview
sixth release will include blazer web
assembly again so we've
we've finally got blazer webassembly
onto the mainline.net 5
track now and then once that's in we're
going to be working on
a bunch of improvements that have been
long requested i think the highest
priority
one of all is stuff to do with
performance and that's both build time
performance
and runtime performance that is a big
focus of the team
and we'll be looking to find ways of
creating some pretty big gains in that
during net five there are also some
programming model improvements
that we have lined up inside the
component apis that have been long
requested by the community
such as the ability to add type
constraints and require parameters and
things like that
which you may know about if you're
already inside the blazer community
another highly requested feature is css
isolation uh which we are working on at
the moment
we've also got some web assembly
specific improvements that we're looking
at
uh we are still exactly figuring out how
much of this
is really possible to achieve on the
time that we've got so there's no
specific promises here
but we're looking at things like the
ability to do true simultaneous
multi-threading which is not something
you can normally do in javascript but
the web assembly runtimes give us the
ability to do that
and the ability to load parts of your
application incrementally
or as some people call it lazy loading
okay
so that's all i've got for pre-prepared
content if you want to get started and i
hope you do then the best place to start
is blazer.net which gives you all the
information you need
to get started on whichever platform you
prefer to do your coding
on and if you want the code from this
talk the car checker example app
then you can go to the url that you can
see here aks.ms blazer dash car checker
and you
will get to a git repo which includes
the source code for the application
so you can try it out and dig into it a
bit more yourself
okay so we have got a few minutes that i
tried to leave at the end
where i can hopefully answer the
questions
uh we'll see and i am going to have a
look at that now
so someone is saying aaron is saying how
easy is it to write a wrapper
for an existing javascript library if
it's not already available
well the answer is it depends on whether
the javascript library has a nice api to
interact with or not
but as long as it does then you can make
calls into javascript
using the js interop apis
which you can see the example that i
showed you before which was
in local vehicle store so you can see
that this is an example of making a call
into javascript
you can deal with passing arbitrary data
which gets json serialized or receive
arbitrary
json serialized data you can call
asynchronous methods
uh you can have javascript call your.net
code including asynchronous methods and
that all works out
okay if you want an example of this
done then you could if you want to go to
what is it called
something like blazer um
let's see get actually i'll post a link
into the chat later on when i find it
of a nice example of a package that
wraps up
some um javascript interrupt code okay
so uh atomos is asking can you use
message format with localizer
yes you can an example of that would be
here
when we are localizing this welcome
message we say welcome
and then we can inject sub strings into
that
such as the user's first name i hope
that answers that
um let's see
rhiann is saying does the localizer work
velocity works with resets files can we
integrate it with a third-party tool
the answer is as long as your
third-party tool is based on getting
stuff from
satellite assemblies then yes that
should just work by default
but how well it works is simply going to
be a question of how well
this third-party system is able to run
on a
net standard environment like blazer
webassembly
uh the question is the pwa support
released yes
it's very much released it was not
delayed i don't know where that rumor
came from
okay any other questions
looks like maybe all the questions are
answered
so get your questions in quickly if you
do have any more
otherwise i'm going to be signing off
and giving you a bit of time
to go and try out blazer webassembly
yourself
uh is there any obfuscation in.net for
webassembly
well microsoft doesn't get any
obfuscation tools so there's nothing
built in
with blazer or any other.net technology
but third-party tools do exist and since
inside the browser we're just
running.net assemblies regular.net
assemblies
they don't have to be translated into
webassembly then
any third-party obfuscator should work
as long as it doesn't do anything
that's so weird that it's not really
even compatible with
net anymore any limitations on
integrating third party.net business
logic
the limitation is that blazer web
assembly runs on net standard 2.1
so as long as your business logic
package
targets net standard 2 1 or below then
it should work
absolutely fine there are some
exceptions to
which apis are supported because of
course your code is still running inside
a browser sandbox
so you can't do things like directly
read and write files from the local file
system
you can't mess around with the user's
windows registry or things like that
because of course the browser sandbox
does not have any way of permitting that
but for any part of net standard that
makes sense in a browser it should work
and for things like business logic as
long as it's just logic and it doesn't
for example directly talk to a sql
database then you should be able to find
that that works absolutely fine what's
the coolest use of blazer that you've
seen before
uh i don't know i'll have to think about
that i don't want to
unfairly ignore people's school projects
so i'll think about that and maybe
respond
in chat later on and
i think i might wind this up now unless
anyone gets a question in really quick
give you another few seconds
christopher myhill bristol
on there great talk cool all right
thanks everyone i think we'll call that
uh
done for the questions now we're just
coming up to the end of the talk so
let's say that we're all done there
for any more questions you can post to
me on slack
or probably better still would be going
to the github repo and filing issues or
going to
the blazer getter channel so that'll do
for now i'm going to sign off i hope you
have
a superb rest of conference
thank you everybody